hey Vsauce Michael here coming to you
from the Barbican in London it's
beautiful it's like living inside the
reckon stein library that's a concrete
joke but I have put together a Leanback
of videos all around YouTube that I
really like that I host as a playlist
you can start it by clicking the link at
the top of this video's description it's
best if you're on a computer or a laptop
something like that but to make it worth
your time in this video I'm going to
share some facts I learned this week
that were quite surprising and cool for
instance being attractive might actually
mean that you are better if you play
American football when females were
asked to rank the hotness of male
American football players there was a
quite surprising correlation the players
that the females ranked as being hotter
also tended to be the players with the
highest passing ratings passing not like
passing in a car with a with a football
but passing in a car brings up the
question of gas prices when gas prices
go up fewer people drive and when fewer
people are driving there are fewer
accidents it's actually quite
mathematical it has been shown that for
every 10% increase in the cost of gas
the number of car accidents goes down by
2.3 percent
fewer accidents means fewer deaths and
here's a fact about death more people
have died inside the Halo games than
have ever died in real life on earth
throughout the entire history of humans
being around killing somebody in real
life makes you a murderer but the
definitions of terms like that are very
specific for instance if you kill four
or more people at one time you are
technically considered by the FBI a mass
murderer and if you kill two or more
people sometimes three or more people
with a time gap in between those events
a cooling down period you are
technically a serial killer based on the
number of unsolved murders
criminologists estimate that in the
United States at any given time there
are about 100 serial killers who have
yet to be caught walking amongst us so
keep your eyes peeled or blink if you
want to I mean the average person blinks
15 times a minute but when you watch
television or youtube videos you blink
even less frequently only about seven
and a half times a minute
so why blink more often than you have to
go ahead and click the link at the top
of the description to play the Vsauce
Leanback it's sure to keep your eyes
open because it's full of videos around
the topic of surprise I'll see you over
there be sure to subscribe to vsauce for
more videos and as always thanks for
watching